بدايه الى هذا الخبر العاجل ووارد على
شاشه الجزيره قتابي تفيد بتفجيرها عبوه
مضاده للافراد في قوه صهيونيه داخل مبنى
في خزاعه شرق خان يونس وايقاع افرادها بين
قتيل وجريح كتائب القسام قالت ايضا انها
اجهزت على قوه صهيونيه من ثمانيه جنود من
مسافه صفر بعد ايقاع في كمين محكم و وسط
بني سهيله شرق خانيونس والاشتباك مع اخرى
وايقاع افرادها بين قتيل وجريح كما استهدف
مقاتلوا القسام في عمليه مشتركه مع سرايا
القدس ثلاث دبابات ميركافا اسرائيليه
بقذائف الياسين 105 وتندم في منطقه معن
بخانيونس جنوبي القطاع وفي بلده خزاعه شرق
خانيونس استهدفت كتائب القسام جرافه
اسرائيليه بقذيفه الياسين 105
وفي منطقه الزنه شرق خانيونس فجر مقاتلو
القسام عبوات مضاده للافراد في قوتين
اسرائيليتين تمركزت احداهما في منزل
وتقدمت الاخرى سوب فتحه نفق واوقع بين
قتيل وجريح وفي منطقه الزنه ايضا اعلنت
القسام استهداف ناقله جند اسرائيليه من
نوع نمر بقذيفه الياسين